notorious Mexican drug lord Joaquin el
chapo guzman will not testify in his own
defense at his federal trial in a rare
moment speaking in court yesterday the
61 year old said he will follow his
attorneys advice and decline to take the
stand Guzman has pleaded not guilty to
17 counts including drug trafficking and
money laundering charges
Jericka Duncan is outside at the
courthouse in Brooklyn where a surprise
Hollywood guest made an appearance in
court
tareka good morning good morning yes the
man who plays out chapo on television
says he wanted to see el chapo in person
so he decided to sit in on the trial
yesterday and Al chapo communicated to
him in a way that even surprised the
actor it was just right there Alejandro
Etta seemed almost starstruck by his
face-to-face encounter with the infamous
drug pen he plays in the Netflix series
narcos Mexico Jason Chappell Joaquin el
chapo guzman smiled and waved at Etta
the actor said he came to see El Chapo
in person to help make his portrayal be
as truthful as possible I was shaking in
a way you know inside out it was didn't
know what to do I just paying my respect
is sailing these tents and
it was a very surreal moment I have to
be honest looking Edda however was not
shaken in his belief that our chapo once
the most wanted man in the world belongs
behind bars
prosecutors say el chapo was the
mastermind behind a multibillion-dollar
drug gang that put more narcotics on
American streets than anyone in history
over 220 tons of cocaine alone more than
50 witnesses testified against El Chapo
since November it was an unprecedented
look at the inner workings of the
Sinaloa cartel CBS News legal analyst
Ricky Kleeman when you look at some of
the people who testified against our
chapo we're talking more drug dealers
murderers what makes them credible they
are exactly the kinds of people who
would be involved in the major drug
business you are not going to find
Saints who are working in the drug
cartels particularly the Sinaloa drug
cartel El Chapo's attorneys are trying
to convince the jury their client was
framed by the real leader of the Sinaloa
cartel who they say remains at large how
does the defense attorney try to turn
this around short of putting his client
on the stand most lawyers would
certainly say you would never put a
criminal defendant on the stand who has
so much baggage and in this case how
would he ever be cross-examined you have
tapes you have encrypted phone calls and
texts everything has now become open
well the defense is expected to call one
of two witnesses today and closing
arguments could start as early as
tomorrow if convicted El Chapo faces
life in prison Nora Marita Rica thank
you